ich habe mich gefragt wie weit kommt man
eigentlich in 24 Stunden wenn man jeden
Zug bis zur Endstation nimmt und immer
nur in die gleiche Richtung fährt
deswegen bin ich morgen zum 39 von
meinem Heimatbahnhof aus losgefahren von
dort aus fahren keine Fernzüge deswegen
der erste regional Jet ging nach
Düsseldorf dort bin ich umgestiegen in
ein ICE Richtung Frankfurt am Main um
kurz vor 12 Uhr bin ich da angekommen
und von dort aus ging es nach Basel in
die Schweiz ich habe so gegen 14 Uhr die
Schweiz französische Grenze überquert
und bin in Mühlhaus gelandet da muss ich
erstmal was essen und bin dann von dort
aus um 16 Uhr mit einem weiteren TGV bis
nach Südfrankreich nach Marseille
gefahren um kurz vor 10 Uhr abends bin
ich dort angekommen und in Frankreich
fahren nachts keine Züge deswegen bin
ich in Marseille gestrandet und hat mir
die Stadt angeschaut wegen eine sehr
schöne Stadt das war eigentlich eine
coole Erfahrung und eine coole Reise
bald mache ich das natürlich auch noch
mal eine andere Richtung